I hate intro shokugeki no souma episode
1 really kicked things off with the
cooking battle between the main
character Yuki here - soma and his
father Joey Trudeau ending in an
eye-opening foodgasm Tuomas fred Mayumi
is the acting judge and she chooses joy
Trudeau's dish preventing sohma's dream
of finally beating is that after trying
489 times the next day Joey judo is off
tending to other matters when a land
shark who wants to shut down the
restaurant and build a hotel comes by
Sheree devises a plan to send some of
her goons over and ruin their meet after
all the meat has been sabotage she
strolls in to order a meat dish saying
that they should stay true to their word
and shut down if they can't serve her so
Emma takes her up on this challenge and
makes a delicious meal out of some
potatoes and bacon that he had lying
around forcing of foodgasm and ultimate
submission from the shark he then finds
out that his dad is shutting down the
restaurant for three years and he's
going to be sent to the best culinary
school in Japan yep so - upon arrival to
the school soma is mocked by some of the
other students for coming from a small
diner having that knockety also known as
the god tug and the tenth seat in the
school's elite student council called
the Elite ten is judging the entrance
exams all of the students freaked out
and give up after she changes some of
the rules except for soma soma takes on
her challenge and even though his dish
gives her a dirty in jail with foodgasm
she fails them because she doesn't like
him and the last scene her grandfather
sends him on who was the director of the
school overruled her decision after
trying sohmas dish episode 3 during the
entrance ceremony soma has to make a
speech since he was the only transfer
student that made it in he claims that
he will be the top student which pisses
pretty much everybody off for their
first assignment he gets paired up with
the timid girl named Meg Amita Dakota
who is on the verge of failing out of
the school
mirror instructor is a French teacher
named Roland Chappell who was judging if
they pass the assignment while cooking
so much dishes sabotage by some nameless
idiots because of what he said at the
entrance ceremony they have to improvise
but ultimately make it by and pass a
test while the two idiots mess up their
dish in the process and fail episode 4
also known as the side character intro
episode suma makes his way to where he
is staying at the PolarStar dormitory he
is immediately tested by the caretaker
Fumio
you know and easily crushes the test on
his first try he then goes on to meet
the rest of the students staying at the
dormitory as well
we have Madhuri Zanjeer Yoshino you keep
cookie ryuko thorgy oh kid i go yo Socky
show giza Toshi and last but not least
the shy girl megameter dokuro from the
first test they all get plastered on
some rice juice wink wink rice eaters
and everybody passes out ishke and some
are the only ones left awake so he
decides to cook a meal for him he then
reveals that he is actually the seventh
seat in the elite ten and once so much
to have a cook-off with his dish yep so
five so mine presses everybody with this
dish and the cook-off is declared a draw
the next day someone makes an official
challenge to ishke with the seventh seat
on the line but gets denied he learns
that a challenge like that has to be a
shokugeki but since he has nothing to be
equal value to the seventh seat ishke
doesn't accept the challenge we get an
example of an official shokugeki when a
team athena when adding a manhandled
Saran and pudgy side character named
gota bye ashie shape or her tent see on
the line in order to get rights to his
club room once he loses a shokugeki the
room that he was fighting for it gets
destroyed to make room for her new
facilities episode 6 so my and the
others have PolarStar start their day
working on forums harvesting fresh
ingredients later on him and Megami go
to look for a Research Society to join
which is equivalent to a school club
suma takes interest in the Don Research
Society but when he goes to check it out
he is told by the president Kenichi
Konishi that oedema is targeting that
club as well one of her lackeys Akuma
Mito is handling the destruction of the
club so so much challenges her to a
shokugeki with his expulsion on the line
the main ingredient meat I'll just leave
this soma Megaman Konishi used the three
days they have to prepare for the
shokugeki trying out new dishes looking
for the perfect one to challenge her
episode 7 the shokugeki gets underway
and Mito busts out her premium
top-of-the-line a5 beef well sama on the
other hand is cooking with budget
markdown meat this discrepancy is made
up for in the cooking and soma ends up
pulling ahead in the final decision as
the second part of the bat Mito is
forced to join the Don Research Society
she isn't that mad about it though
because she thinks that some was gonna
be in it who she's kind of crushing on
but to her dismay
Souma actually turned down joining the
club so she is left alone with Konishi
as the only other member episode 8 the
first years at the academy are now going
to the training camp from hell which is
really just another challenge to weed
out the weaker students the alumni of
the academy who are well renowned chefs
are brought in to act as judges in their
performance they're split into groups
again and what do you know someone ends
up with mega meat your instructor is the
former second seat he not go Anu who
gives them the task of collecting
ingredients from the wilderness and
making a dish with them also in their
group is Taku me aldini who challenges
so much because of again what he said at
the entrance ceremony
dr. meas are working with his pudgy
brother he saw me and they prepare a
duck that easily passes the test episode
9 doctor me set the bar pretty high so
sama has to think outside the box and
comes up with the idea of using in new
ways aki peanuts as breading first fish
this rounds out the dish nicely so Hema
Megami passed the test wouldn't they ask
which dish was better he knew he almost
answers but it's called away before she
can so it ends in a draw talk to me
isn't satisfied with that which makes
soma his newfound rival that he's
obsessed with beating when the students
return to their hotel they are given the
surprise task of fixing 50 servings of
steak for the bodybuilding wrestling and
football clubs Toma finishes way before
anybody else so he decides to go to a
communal bath assuming that nobody's
gonna be there this keeps some anime
cliches when he runs into ed ena as
she's getting out of the bath episode 2
any mess still hate soma and is mad
because she let down her guard around
him but nothing really happens in the
exchange game Dojima who used to go to
the Academy and is the head chef at the
resort is in the bath when soma gets
there they have a nice chat or whatever
but Dojima ends up leaving as Takamiya
arrives DOMA and Megami are in the same
group again the next day but this time
they have to work by themselves cool
judo shinomiya is leading the class and
while soma passes ko judo ends up
failing mega me because she was forced
to deviate from the recipe suma
disagrees with the decision to expel her
so he calls him out after ignoring his
complaint soma kicks things up a notch
when he challenges kojirou to Ashoka
Kiki Taurus and Maggie's expulsion
shokugeki
episode 11 core judo tonight's a
challenge at first but is forced to
accept by Dojima andi nui who overhear
the situation and pressure him until he
gives in as they're about to start
cooking kojima throws in a twist
saying that Megami is actually going to
be the head chef with soma assisting her
they bring in three of the alumni to act
as judges for the shokugeki go judo
finishes his dish first and sends all
the judges spiraling through vibrant fou
gazans and in the last scene Megami
presents her dish as well episode 12
Megumi finishes her dish and delivers it
to the judges and impresses them all but
when it comes down to the vote kazuto
still wins in a landslide before he can
leave though Dojima casts his vote for
mega meat and points out that ko judo
has let his cooking get stale
metaphorically we get a flashback of
koshiro's first restaurant and how he
lost Direction once he accomplished his
goals whose judo is pressured by the
others to taste mega meas dish and he
sees how much care was put into it so he
ends up casting his vote for mega me as
well you know he decides to throw in her
vote because the judging's already asked
backwards at this point so who cares
this ties up the votes 3 to 3 so ko
Judah decides to resend the expulsion
episode 13 after a long day of cooking
all the students are tired and worn out
but get called down for their next
assignment they have to work through the
night without any rest to come up with a
new egg dish to serve to customers
buffet style well I'm pretty sure this
would be illegal I don't think you can
just make minors work through the night
but you know anime so whatever summer
decides to make a souffle but the others
are kind of giving off this vibe like
it's a bad idea in order to pass the
students must give out 200 plates to the
customers and Eva quickly crushes the
200 plate gold with others close behind
but in the last scene we see that soma
is struggling with less than ten plates
episode 14 - masu plays the plate before
the customer can enjoy them which is why
everybody was giving off that negative
oh you're screwed vibe he has to calm
himself down and does what anybody would
do in the situation and lures a little
girl into his booth really girly
you want some souffles this whole scene
I was just waiting for the little girl
to go into food guess not because I
wanted to see it but I haven't talked to
the FBI in a while and I'm worried about
them
meanwhile soma finally gets some
traction and starts churning out
souffles before they can Flay and
narrowly makes the 200 plate goal while
talking with
Idina afterwards he meets Alison akuti
who is head enas cousin and finished in
second with the amount of plates served
losing only to Eddie nough reel so meet
her brooding companion buyo Kudo kiba
but we don't learn too much about him
with the training camp finally winding
down the students are treated to a meal
prepared by the alumni as a reward for
passing yep so 15 as the students are
preparing to head back to the Academy
soma runs into kazuto who is heading
back to france with a newfound
determination the other alumni try
offering soma and Megami jobs after they
graduate because the camp is also a
scouting ground for restaurant owners
soma and Idina both end up missing their
bus so they have to ride back together
while Edina reluctantly fills him in on
the next big event the autumn elections
when soma gets back to the dormitory he
is surprised to find his dad there who
is preparing dinner for him and the
others turns out his dad used to be the
second seat in the elite tenth right
behind kojima who was the first seat
they were both a part of polar star
dormitory during it's golden age the
next day his dad wakes him up and
challenges him to a cook-off to see how
much he's improved yep so 16 we find out
that ed ena actually knows Joey cheeto
and keeps a photo of him from when she
met him as a child anyways back to the
cook-off between soma and his dad with
ishq a mega me and Fumio acting as the
judges they are tasked by Fumio to make
a light morning meal to get them started
with the day suma makes an apple risotto
well Joey judo decides to go with a
light ramen even though sohma's dish
seems good it just can't compare to Joey
Judas so he loses for the 490 of time
without getting a single vote you'll eat
you don't leave shortly after but tell
somebody to go check up on the
restaurant that has been closed since
they both left
episode 17 Oh Greg rolls around and soma
heads home to check on the restaurant
like his dad asked him to when he gets
there he runs back into Colossae and
some of her friends he reopens the
restaurant temporarily to cook for some
of the usuals where he finds out that
the shopping district they're located in
is struggling a new khadija shop has
been pulling all their customers away
Zuma wants to
off the shopping district so he decides
that he's gonna make his own cottage a
recipe to compete with them and get
their customers back he calls in the
meat expert Akuma to help since this is
her speciality there you go to try out
the new category sippy where they meet
the opposition CEO kinu naka mozu who is
kind of spiteful in the last scene we
get a look at the person responsible for
Nakamatsu success at suya Aizen who is
the ninth seat in the elite ten episode
18 since they can't find a recipe better
than nakumo zeus they switched their
focus to the packaging and opted into a
more on the move approach this is a big
hit amongst the customers and brings a
ton of traffic back into the shopping
district to keep the Cata get sales up
while he's away he asked Kudo say to
help out instead when he returns Aizen
requests a meeting with him and
confronts him about stealing business
from his client nothing really comes of
it but he also tells soma that he's been
chosen for the autumn elections episode
19 the autumn elections are made up of
60 contestants selected by the elite ten
for a split into two groups and compete
with one another
mega Mir was also selected by the elite
ten and is approached by another
contestant Miyako hosho who is
interested in mega me because of her
shokugeki with Coach Ito who shows
disappointed when mega me says that it
was actually mostly so miss doing that
she survived it anyways the dish that
they're gonna be making in the autumn
elections is announced to be some sort
of curry so Manny mega me head down to
meet with Jun Shiomi who used to be Joey
kudos underclassmen well there they meet
with her assistant Akita hi Yama
hi Yama specializes in his ability to
cook with this hypersensitive nose any
vows to beat soma while winning the
election II episode one ting there are
only six weeks remaining until the
autumn elections so students are all
preparing in their own way Zuma's taking
this time to try out new spice
combinations for his curry we also find
out a little bit more about the
competition the top four from each group
will make it out of the prelims and move
on to the tournament phase where you
jump ahead to the start of the autumn
election so most of the episode is just
showing all the major characters
preparing their meals man and the last
scene we get a little bit of a debate
when everybody is shocked to see some
sleep attestation episode 21
Tomer wasn't actually asleep he was just
like meditating to sense when his dish
was just right out of
we're team boo then we jump over to
Megami who impresses everybody with her
ability to cut a massive monkfish what's
the time runs out everybody finishes up
their meals and we move on to the
judgment of the dishes we take a look at
a few going on in Group B with a new
character now Sarika who is kind of a
yawn today with an obsession for ED inna
and in the other corner is Ed eNOS
secretary an childhood friend he Sokka a
Tito who specializes in medicinal
cuisines it's not much of a fight when a
de tous smashes the yonder they score
with a ninety two out of a hundred
taking the lead in Group E after sub
Attica tries out a tous dish
she's so purified by the qualities that
she transforms and becomes obsessed with
audit Oh instead of Adina episode 22
let's go ahead and wrap up Group B Milko
scores an 87 Yuki manages to get an 86
we have the two eldini brothers face off
after he saw me surprised weight loss
through bad that doesn't help with his
cooking so he loses to his older brother
87 to 90 Alice comes out of nowhere and
amazes the judges with her unorthodox
dish so she claims lead with a 95 Megami
is almost forgotten about but what she
presents her dish she gets an 88 barely
making it into the top four and
qualifying for the tournament round the
other three contestants I qualified from
Group B are Hisako taka me and of course
the leader Alice episode 23 jump on over
to group a were one of the judges knots
and may send a water I'm thirsty keeps
giving contestants hero's Alice's friend
could occupy uses his flavours to seduce
her and finally puts an end to the zero
streak with a new high score of 93 Akuma
is the next one to make a splash with a
score of 86
ryuko matches the 86 when she presents
her dish battery and eboo sake also get
matching scores when they present their
dishes and both get eighty eight bullets
face it they're all side characters so
their scores are never really gonna
matter let's head on over to an actual
character Ikeda whose dish looks
ordinary but when they cut into it
they're greeted by a fragrance bomb that
envelops the room episode 24 a Kiva's
dish is of course a huge hit with the
judges so he lands himself in 94 now
it's tsoumas turn to try it out do this
newfound rival ironically enough p2 had
the idea of making a fragrance bomb with
his dish once again it was the judges
but he ends up getting a 93
finishing in second to akhira in the
standings although so am i finished in
second he gets a bit of a consolation
prize when the judges start arguing
amongst each other saying that sohma's
dish was actually better and that he
should have been first they all head
back to the dorms and proceeded to get
wasted to celebrate surviving the
prelims but now everybody has to turn
their sights to the main tournament
where the top eight are gonna square off
I'm gonna be doing the next season and
that'll be in the bottom left whenever
I'm finished with it or you can check
out all the shokugeki recaps in this
playlist here you can also find the
links in the description below and the
only thing I hate more than intros is
our four controls